TOP OF THIS HOUR.
DR. NICOLE SAPHIER.
JONATHAN SERRIE FROM ATLANTA
AND WE BEGIN WITH JOHN ROBERTS
THE CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WE DON’T HAVE ANY TIMING ON
THAT VOTE THIS AFTERNOON.
A LOT OF PROCEDURAL HURDLES
THAT HAVE TO BE WAIVED.
LATER ON TODAY THE SENATE WILL
BE VOTING ON THE MASSIVE $2
TRILLION FISCAL STIMULUS BILL.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
COMING TO AN AGREEMENT LATE
LAST NIGHT.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER MITCH
MCCONNELL ON WHAT THEY
ACCOMPLISHED.
>> RUSH NEW RESOURCES TO THE
FRONT LINES OF THE NATION’S
HEALTHCARE FIGHT AND INJECT
TRILLIONS OF CASH INTO THE
ECONOMY AS FAST AS POSSIBLE TO
HELP AMERICAN WORKERS,
FAMILIES, SMALL BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRIES MAKE IT THROUGH THIS
DISRUPTION.
EMERGE ON THE OTHER SIDE READY
TO SOAR.
>> Ed: SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
SENDING A LETTER TO HIS
COLLEAGUES SAYING WE HAVE
REACHED AND AGREEMENT TO
ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, SUPPORT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND PUT AMERICA’S
WORKERS FIRST.
HERE IS WHAT THE 2 TRILLION
PORTION SAYS.
120 BILLION FOR HOSPITALS, 120
BILLION FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, 350 BILLION FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES, FOUR MONTHS
OF UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER FORCED TO
QUARANTINE OR LAID OFF FROM
WORK AND $1200 CASH PAYMENTS
FOR ADULTS, $500 PER CHILD.
ALSO ACCESS TO SOME $4 TRILLION
OF LIQUIDITY FROM THE FEED.
WHEN AMERICAN CAN GET BACK TO
WORK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
BY EASTER SUNDAY APRIL 12th BUT
ACKNOWLEDGING HE CAME UP WITH
THAT DATE BECAUSE HE JUST
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE GOOD TO DO
IT.
LISTEN HERE.
>> President Trump: EASTER IS A
VERY SPECIAL DAY FOR MANY
REASONS.
FOR ME, FOR A LOT OF OUR
FRIENDS.
THAT’S A VERY SPECIAL DAY.
AND WHAT A GREAT TIMELINE THIS
WOULD BE.
EASTER IS OUR TIMELINE, WHAT A
GREAT TIMELINE THAT WOULD BE.
MY FIRST PRIORITY IS ALWAYS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> IT’S UNLIKELY THE COUNTRY
COULD OPEN UP ALL AT ONCE.
COULD BE CERTAIN AREAS OF
NATION LESS AFFECTED CAN GET
BACK TO BUSINESS WHILE OTHER
AREAS LIKE NEW YORK TY MAY
REMAIN RESTRICTED.
I ASKED DR. TONY FAUCI ABOUT
THAT AT THE CORONAVIRUS
BRIEFING YESTERDAY AND HERE IS
WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU CAN LOOK AT A DATE BUT
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE ON
A DAY-BY-DAY AND WEEK-BY-WEEK
BASIS.
YOU NEED TO EVALUATE THE
FEASIBILITY OF WHAT YOU ARE
TRYING TO DO.
AND JOHN, YOU ASKED FOR WHAT
KIND OF METRICS, WHAT KIND OF
DATA.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COUNTRY,
OBVIOUSLY NO ONE IS GOING TO
WANT TO TONE DOWN THINGS WHEN
YOU SEE WHAT’S GOING ON IN A
PLACE LIKE NEW YORK CITY.
THAT’S JUST GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH
PRACTICE AND COMMON SENSE.
THE COUNTRY IS A BIG COUNTRY.
>> AFTER THE VOTE TODAY IF IT
IS PASSED IN THE SENATE THAT
FISCAL STIMULUS BILLS GOES TO
THE HOUSE.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI WITH
DEFINITE IDEAS OF WHAT SHE
THINKS SHOULD BE KNIT.
SHE WILL LOOK AT IT LATER TODAY.
THE HOUSE IS ADJOURNED UNTIL
11:00 A.M. TOMORROW.
SO IT IS LIKELY THERE WON’T BE
ANY VOTE IN THE HOUSE SO WHILE
IT MAY PASS THE SENATE LIKELY
WOULDN’T PASS THE HOUSE UNTIL
SOMETIME TOMORROW IF THEY CAN